within the next 15 seconds you're
probably going to say this is one of the
most
unique interviews we've ever had on
valuetainment and here's why
my guest today is latif yahya who is
known he's living his own life right now
doing his thing but prior to this he
lived a very interesting life one day
he gets a knock on the door by uh his
classmate who happens to be saddam
hussein's son
uday uh and he says i want you to be my
double
and he says what do you mean double he
says i want you to be my double he turns
him down at first and then he's going to
tell you what happens next
there was a book written about us saying
i was saddam son
a movie that i watched the moment it
came out in 2011 called
the devil's devil with that being said
my guest today latif
yahya thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
you're welcome so latif i think it's
fair to say
you've lived an interesting life
hard life we can't say interesting for
me
was from the minute i joined this team
by force wasn't an enjoyable
moment or enjoyable job to do
now before that happening let's go back
a little bit let's go back on how
you got connected with saddam hussein's
family how did that relationship come
about
uh we was together in the same school in
high school we spent few years together
same school this was a special school
for all the
high educated people minister zones
politician zones and was close to my
home too and here
we was met first time in he was
in my school and my
class and
i was very worried as advice from my dad
to don't be nearly off those family or
the government or anything my father is
very peaceful
man rest in peace now and
i listened to him but
the problem was what are they at the
time and they
start we become nearly know each other i
was painting i love painting since i was
child
and when the saddam hussein become a
president he was the vice president
iraq
i paint his picture and
and full size in the big picture
and he's he look at him and say wow you
know
this is nice this is that and he took it
off me
and from here started so so
so you had met saddam hussein before
through his son uday or or was that
uh was no uh this is you met saddam this
is a time
this is was a school competition
painting and all day he thought
he saw the painting and he took it i got
it
and so in 1979 is when he became a
president
so when you said you were in high school
with uday what year was that
uh up till
i finished my university in 1987
four years before that for four and a
half years yeah
so he was he was already president he
was already a powerful man he was
already
you know had a reputation and for some
that don't know i mean this is
before we go into that angle one of the
things i want to know from you is even
prior to him being a president
i'm from iran so i i've had to study a
lot of saddam hussein because you know
i was born in 78 so if i'm born 78
four months before the shot went in
exile october of 17th
you know my lifeline i stayed there
until uh 1989 so i was there for the
whole war between iran and iraq it
wasn't the
prettiest thing but who was saddam
hussein before he became president and
vice president
way before that saddam hussein he was a
head of we say intelligence service at
the time they call it hanin
what this was protect and bad party
and because of his background and
he's very clever person you know because
we can't deny that
but uh he be he'd been elected by
our party to start what called
intelligence service and he named it
hanin means
something is very hard to explain
but anyway he become the head of
intelligent service of bad party before
all this happened and they was
assassinate
all these people what not belong to them
or against them or
do stuff against bad party till he
become
a vice president so he was known as
someone that
some called him a hitman some called him
a vicious man
some called him a fearless man but he
was
he was feared amongst people way before
he got into politics would you agree
with that
i agree with that because this is his
story and
he he he himself he was saying that
i start this and i start that and
[Music]
he was saying always this chair
didn't come easy to me was something
we did with our colleagues with our
brothers
to get to this power got it okay so now
let's fast forward you're in high school
you will do there you make draw this
painting he sees it
he likes it were you guys best friends
or were you just classmates when he
first saw this
classmate i can't say it because i
didn't like it from day one i
arrived to my class in pacific
you know first of all uh
he was common with his porsche he was a
teenager
and you have a porsche yellow porch very
stupid color yellow is not
even normal color and
with painting i was this is my hobby i
was
playing basketball and he come and put
his car
where is the basketball place you know
he don't let anybody play basketball he
don't he harassed and
anybody at the time we have this
you know uh
we're talking 70s and beginning eighties
he's
afro here you know big hairs and
[Music]
he have really big big hair you know
and uh he come on two three security
with him always
just stand up around when he come to the
class
because he was taller of us he was
sitting in the back
and two people sit one here and one here
and one beside him
right for him all the teachers say he
don't
do anything this was
his uh attention in the class
but i can't deny he was very very clever
so he was also clever like his father
interesting he's very clever he's very
clever but
in a meaningful mean way in a mean way
yeah and he don't like to see somebody
higher of him or clever more on him or
answer the teacher in a good way he be
really upset
because he think he's a bigger person
he's a more powerful
even with god he have so much
jealousy inside him i don't know after i
we met and sit and i understand why he
was suffering from that
was he did he have a reputation even
then in high school
as somebody who was ruthless or he
hadn't developed a reputation yet
in the beginning he was very shy to be
fair he was very very shy
but the second year start all these
exaggeration stuff because you know as
you are from middle east and we are
never you know as a
school separate boys and girls you know
only
on in university but as a boy schools
he coming with a girlfriend and
was the closest school for a girl beside
us he picked his girlfriend and come to
this school
with his girlfriend sitting in class
and one of the teacher he asked him you
know you're not allowed to do that
and you know uh please
take this girl out of here
anyway anyway we didn't never saw the
teacher anymore i don't know what's
happened to him
also when the teacher told to take the
girl out you never saw the teacher ever
again
yeah we know what song after he left the
class
i don't know where he disappeared got it
so that was a
one mistake right there telling him he
can have girlfriends there so
so did you but did you hear stories with
them like even
when you went to high school did you see
him fighting did you see him
killing yet did you see him doing
anything yet during high school was
there any signs yet
no killing no fight
we can say in a mean way yeah he always
pushing people like that
but he always have a gun small gun
magnum he always carry with him any
school
in a high school you know you can't have
a gun
but he come and he's always put it in
his pocket or he put it in
he have a cover for a gun beside his leg
and he sometimes play with it like that
you know
there's a lot of people
special in the school was want to be
close to him because he's the power and
you know
us middle east people like power people
like that
at the time you know my family is
the rich family and known in baghdad
i have a car too and this age but it
wasn't a porsche
you know we can't say porsche like
there's something
just my dad he worked for me and in this
age you can't
have even a car i don't have even a
license
but uh something you know this
you know middle eastern business people
do the fantasy okay my
son is under age but he's driving a car
you know
i have a ladder the first car
yeah my first car was a ladder but at
the time
we talked in seventies zlatan was
something won't come to iraq
and especially this ladder was a story
in 1979 when the iraq
football win something champion
the president ahmed hassan bakker he
import from russia or soviet union
because he's made their lada
footballer as a present as a gift uh
and when the first car has been sold my
dad bought it for me my birthday
and was ladder you know wow you know
somebody have a ladder
and uh what i want
till we finish school i get a
good degree and good numbers
my dream was really up till now in this
age
my dream to be an engineer i like to be
an
engineer civil engineer building these
houses
i still turn this age even i didn't go
to university of engineering i still
drawing you know how i do i designed
all my house how many houses i have
in europe i designed all my houses how i
like it
and when i went to university
uh i saw other he's applied there
i said i'm not spending another four or
five days with this idiot
i want to the law something absolutely
out of the numbers i get
i can be md or engineer
or the numbers i get but
i want to the law it's very classy i say
okay we go to the law
finish my degree
and at the time you know was iraq iran
war
any soldier they need officers they need
by iraqi law when you finish school or
university or you don't go to school
unless you do
the army things you know
at the time when you are educated
university and like that they give you a
ring of officer
on your shoulder but if you don't have
an it
be just soldier because i was tall
and at the time you know healthy and
muscles and like that
they picked me to be a commandos
you know we went to the commandos
training six month straight away to the
war
we was in a battle you know as iranian
as a shame to two nations to be
fighting each other for no reason up
till now i fight
and i'm left nearly 30 years out until
now i don't know why we fight
you know i don't understand what's
happened between these two countries
because our relation when the shah was
was
different from on the command
[Music]
as i hear because my dad he was going
holiday to iran in the shack and
he was same as parish of middle east
it's so nice all
this and that but you know politics
change and
the stuff has changed and khomeini come
on
we start hating each other wars start
and
you know wars are not a fun thing
it is not something to enjoy no matter
no matter what you do is not a fun
place to go and i was seeing you know in
front of me my soldier be killed i've
been
injured several times
i see iranian dead i see iraqi dead
but all was the question in my head
why we are here you know in my head
i was more open and politic but in my
head
my father he hate politics they say
don't talk politics don't say anything
you know even
the wall have ear to hear you in iraq
and this is the problem with me
even my father was saying to me you
don't listen you have a stone head
what in your head you heard you do it
i was sitting for example in a bunker
and the night sometimes peaceable is not
two three hours no shot hearing no
bombing no nothing
i think with myself i have a candle and
two
soldiers or three soldiers and i say to
them
why we are here why i was saying
loudly to them and they was terrified
because the similarity at the time
between
us and the shape of our face
looked like more i am related to this
family especially tikrit
and al-oja all similar phase thick
mustache and all that
when i was saying to them look we are
brothers here
don't look at my ring don't because i'm
officer but i'm asking you
as a human us iraqi why we are here
why we don't see odai and kosai the
other son
fighting here they care about they don't
know what they answered me because they
think i am one of them and i'm spying
for example or
but anyway one day
my general call me you know we are on
the front line
it was like between us 600 meters no
more on that
between the first line with the iranian
uh he called we have a you know
like a radio it's common called dracul
i like the sir it's you know the general
i said okay
he said you're coming now you leave
everything you come and now
at the time was like a lot of water
around us they send a small boat to us
and bring it and we won i want we say
what did you do lottie i say
i didn't do anything sir you say look at
this letter
coming from us i say
which palace you see how many
palestinians are like there are public
colors
i look at the letter and you know must
be not under
you know a lot if you're here coming in
72 hours to the
palace and like that anyway
i took my car and i want
i want is like a it's like a reception
i'll give the letter i say just sit
there
i wait like 10 15 minutes
um another guy coming
they put me in a car dark you can't see
anything
car is going around and there and left
and right and i don't know where's
going and then i was in front of palace
shaped
the door like a eagle
and here i went inside and
somebody come to me and stay here once a
conservative
okay uh
the other doors open are they
in front of me how are you my friend
how are you keeping jude is in front of
you this is saddam son that's in front
of you
yeah okay and i look at him and
i say i'm good they say well done what
you're doing you have a few medals now
and you're a good fighter and all
these reports coming about you on this
and that
and sit down and you bring a cigar for
me
and he just collects something and
orange was coming and
fruit on the table on us
all the long old days and start talking
and i say to make it short to you
what about you become saddam son
and i smiled and i said to him we are
also dancing
you know and you're like we are all
saddam songs
they say no i want to be
your real saddam son you i wanted to be
my feed i
feed i sacrified yourself or somebody
else
when i tried to play
stupid or idiot and i say what do you
mean bodyguard security you say no
i want you to be okay
they start explaining to me and like
that
but the picture in my head
my dad my mother my sisters my brothers
baghdad iraq everything is going in my
head
uh the report coming from intelligence
service they say you look like me
and ha ha ha he's talking
and i'll say any choice he said to me
yeah sure we have choice we are in a
free country you can say what you want
to say
and if you review i say
if i say yes what happened if i say no
what happened
they say to me if you say yes
you'll be okay my power
everything is you if you say no
i shake hand with you and you go to your
army and finish
i say great i say all day we are
you know friends and
you know i am in the army and you know
we are just another
year or how long got to be i finish i go
with my business
and my dad business and like that and
before even i finished
i see his eyes just like start fire out
of it
and they say this mean
refusing i say you give me the choice
and i'm saying to you was a glass of
juice in my hand he kept him
somebody come and take my ring out
uh holding my eye
my head is down like
push me to the boot of the car not even
in the car
and the boot of the car
driving around like that
kick me from the boot your head down
down
down open a door
and they pushed me straight away i was
to the wall
they took that's what they covered my
eyes were
everything is red light
wall floor door
everything is red painted red
no window no nothing you can't see the
time in it and they should be down
it's one meter by one meter even you
can't
sit or you know not comfortable
and not well yet no nothing this little
hole in the floor and that's it
i don't know how long i spend exactly
but
i was counted six seven days
because even with that they was confuse
me they give me for example in the
breakfast they give me dinner and
dinner they give me breakfast and
you know just to don't know where you
are what time
day or night
uh but you know it's
not too early to smell you know
psychologically after i learn after i
learned
this is more psychologically war coming
from russian
or sovereign union intelligence service
what they was
training the iraqi intelligence service
for that
what called psychologically war
here what six seven days the doors open
was a day and
was another guy with him would he live
in jordan
now and he said to me
did you change your mind now
or do you want me to bring your sisters
here
and you know what this mean
i say no please i do anything you want
leave my family alone
he said okay i was reading or
seven days same clothes dirty and like
this you say come
out i come out they didn't hold my eye
they didn't do anything to me
i come out i saw myself
this is the palace you know of
and they have special prison for really
serious people they hate them
anyway he took me
to the car they drove
about 10 minutes to project seven
called the project seven this is one of
the follows
and here everything
and my life completely changed changed
to
in a bad way in a really bad way
but anybody else if he didn't
come from multi-family for him as wow
or everything you know and i be slave
for him is no problem how he treated me
but
i'm not a slave i'm born free man and
you know sometimes even i don't listen
to my dad because
this is me but
he say look all these people around here
is your now they look after you they do
everything for you
and this and that
go have a shower they bring me some nice
shower you know this is a palace one and
everything you clean nice you know the
perfume is here is this thing
i have my shower they've shown me my
room it's really big beard and
everything is luxury
and they left me a few days there
tofu top grain top everything
i wasn't at the time drinking alcohol
even i didn't you know this heavy smoker
about a week less than week
people come i don't know who they are
but they don't look like hierarchy
they start seeing lottie
strep please what you minister strip
please everything my weight
my height teeth color
skin all that has been checked
i write it down i was short of
shorter you know of a day about three
centimeter three and a half centimeters
oh there you go six six he's very tall
he's very tall so that means you're also
very tall
you're also tall i am tall yeah yeah
uh but not same are they
uh yeah this
between us like they checked everything
was even the voice
very very close you know even even the
doctor
they say how this happened you know
my age i am just four years
older of all day he born 40 i born 14th
of june
64. he born 18th of june 64.
you know i can't be more concerned
wait wait wait you guys are four days
apart from your birthday
yes i am older from four days
wow and they start checking and
everything
uh they say the height you know after a
few days the height
got to be sold you know have a high
shoes they put at the time
uh a general he was my mate
you know just on the bed he don't be
with me he training me
every single thing you know shown me
videos
showing me this show me that
but the training at the time does not
start
till they
did my teeth my front teeth all has been
changed
because other he have teeth forward
they make it exactly like him the gap
between the teeth all that sorted was
the chain they did the operation i have
a beard you can't see it
as open the chin something
[Music]
they drilled on i i did all these
operations when i
come out to the west i took everything
out
and after that i have a break
and really the bad suffering start
my background was not for these things i
didn't saw these things when i was child
i was very soft even the army i was very
soft even we are commandos
because we don't care but i was soft
you know and anyway
training was the first
few weeks watching videos what kind of
videos
are they movement smoking
walking talking moving hand
in a speech how he
stand up how he sit in his chair even
when you come
to sit in your chair and which way you
sit
all that the hard part
start of watching torture
what i never i was hearing about it but
i never saw it
uh the first half an hour less than half
an hour
i become really ill and sick i threw
from my head i can't take it you know
and every time
i true that push my head back watch
i watch and watch and watch and watch
day after day after day and uh
week after week become normal in my eye
and this is again
as a part of intelligent service
training
this past but
the worst is common all these torture i
was seeing in the videos i was sick
but how about to see it live
there was bringing me somewhere the
special prison
and here you see the torture life and
you see
how the people torch it and how
[Music]
the nails steam cables in the back and
everything you know
this when i asked him what he was
the general of intelligent service why
are going through that they say to kill
your heart to don't feel sorry for
anybody
to be part of a party
if you don't be like that you don't
survive
an era you don't survive
as a government and you present his son
sat down son
you don't survive unless you have that
all that is done
and really even my personality starts
changing
but it's still in my back here say i am
lovely
here not others interesting so
so at this point you've watched they've
conditioned your mind they've got to
kill your heart they got to get you to
realize that this is a normal life so
this is not gonna you know uh hurt you
you're getting colder
you're you know becoming a little bit
more uh
acceptance of the life of uh what it
could like to be your day
and going through this so now what what
happens next
after this where you actually get to see
who they and at what point do you start
spending more time with saddam hussein
because they didn't want him to be in
public
in dangerous places they wanted you to
be in public what ways were you used
uh between the training
i was meeting all day time to time he
common it's not like
i finished meeting him it was time to
time he come on to see
and where we are and how we talk
and and he was laughing you know he was
really laughing
and i don't know why but he was laughing
anyway
after all this finished
they come and go have a shower go have
this
go have that
a doctor come on he tested me
and my mouth and that it's like they
have
tissues cleaning my hand they bring
brand new suit branch here everything
new from shoes socks everything is new
what's going on
is don't ask we go to see
about an hour later car come on
money i'm with me another car behind us
and this is where i met the president
for first time
how was his demeanor when you met him
how was he with you
uh he was sitting in his desk and he was
writing something and just put his head
up
and he smiled
[Music]
and he looked at me welcomed on me
he shake my hand sit down i said
was very good very nice
not what we hear about him
funny uh he said
god they give me two sons you are the
third now
anything you want ask anything
in your dream just asked
but try don't make me hungry only this
world
and i said sure sir i don't do anything
make you angry but to be fair
you know he liked me
he really liked me you know he never
hurt me
he always called me a son and he mean it
when he said to me
he always say to my shoulder everything
okay nobody upsetting you you know i'm
okay
that's it got it now at this point your
family
you're not in contact with your family
does your family know what's going on or
no
my family they told them
what if he been killed in the war
but his body we can't get him iranian
pass this line and we can get him
they did a funeral for me nobody know
latif is a different place and
that's it even i still have the picture
of
this the black sign they put when
somebody killed in the war
my name in it and i have the video of
my funeral you have the video of your
funeral
yes i have it uh yeah
i have all these photos they took
for the funeral as an army person he
killed in the war
how long from from that until they found
out you're alive how many years was that
less than two oh less than two years
until they found that okay
got it so so now you're in the family
saddam's calling you his son i had two
now i have three
anybody making you upset you know cry
don't make me hungry
you know he's telling you all this of
his mindset
when did you start seeing how uday lived
and how he behaved
i saw him i think second
week of when i was in the palace when he
was coming you know
he bring girls with him oh if you like
somebody take her take her like
you know lucky
take her you know
i am here for something else
but after i finish
all these planning he start coming
if he don't want me to go for him as a
body
the devil he said okay you come and
party
partying with me shave your beard
okay shave your beard i'll just be more
style
i dress like a just normal food i carry
in a gun
and all that and go behind him with him
in his car but the parties i was seeing
[Music]
i don't think a king or friends
or playboy in the world do these parties
when you say that what do you mean by
that well give us a little bit of
description
one of the parties was his birthday
his lot of
friend close friend to him i don't think
he have a friend but
i call them ken i'm sorry for this world
but
this is the reality what i saw
i call them temps because they bringing
girls
they do every dirty thing just to be
close to him
one of the party was his birthday about
50 girls there and about 20
what called friend
and i was in a corner
having my cigar on a cornea beside me
just past 12 o'clock he took his machine
gun and start
shooting here and there he was
absolutely
blocked drunk
everyone's struck everyone takes the
clothes
everyone took the clothes out all of
them
you don't see any clothes in the place
man and woman this is one of the
craziest things
really till now the picture i can't
imagine that i was there so they take
their clothes off everybody took their
clothes off
yeah and then what happened
okay got it so everybody he was just
asking to okay i got it yeah it makes
sense
yeah i thought you were gonna say he
took out the machine gun and did
something to harm those girls
uh because what what i read about him
you know
and and study about him over the years
because you want to know what the family
was like
uh they say based on what you read about
he was
more sick he was a psycho he was
meaner he was more vicious than his
father ever was
he took the level of viciousness to new
heights is that a pretty true statement
or
was his father more vicious than he was
no he is he passed his father
he passed a lot at least his father when
he was doing
all this stuff he have strategy
in his life he was doing that
for a politic issue for
something he want to get an eric
but although he was doing it for
many acting there's nothing his benefit
of him
uh you don't know what he wants
sometimes you see him really laugh with
a big mouth
and half an hour later sitting in a
corner
crying like a baby that's kind of a day
personality you don't know what he wants
you don't know why he's doing that
uh
when he drunk uh twice i heard from him
he said to me my dad don't like me he
like kosai more on me
this is why he don't want to give me a
power this is why he put kosai
as ahead of his security he didn't put
me
i want to answer him but i i know my
neck could
be bye bye now kosai was a little bit
more reserved to himself he was a
little shy a little quick quiet but he
was calculating he had his dad's
calculating side based on what i read
about him uh
uh but he wasn't that uh public about it
and i know i know there was one time
where he became the leader of secret
service and his dad i think in 1984
made the uday the chairman of the iraqi
olympic
uh committee yeah and he wanted to see
the
service yeah uh
kosai the second son he's more close to
his dad this is why his dad
trusts him more one he's not like oh
they
he married even he's the youngest one
he's very very clever for me personally
i like him uh
very very intelligent he treat his
people with him
as a friend and a brother he don't hurt
him like are they what he do
if he don't like you even your clothes
and my group
are so fun they say okay take him uh
shave his head shave his eyebrows
uh send him to this place where we
torture
okay just for fun for ten days enough
he's joking
and this is what he do but kosai no no
he give a chance
second he sit with you talk
in a human way uh sometimes he said
you don't look at look at me also
brother to your friend why you behave
like that
but saddam and kosai
there was very hard and strong
with their family and they tried for
example
if any iraqi do something wrong i give
an example
maybe get forgiveness and a lot of
forgiveness
happened at the time but anybody
belong to saddam family cousin or cousin
of cuisine
or common from tikrit he'd been 10 times
punished more than normal person
because saddam and kosair was telling
them
when you behaved like that you hated my
name
and saddam to be very honest with you he
was caring about his name so much
i saw one of his
he was cut and yeah he was captain
one of the times they sent me for
torture
and once saddam closes sick
you know security with him and from
tikrit
because he did something unusual in the
street
you know he he hit the traffic light or
something was red and but
he sent him where i was being tortured
for a month
and he's a captain and his saddam family
because he hit a red light yeah
he said because you behave you are
belong to saddam name when people
know you are my bodyguard and behave
like that how the normal people go to
respect the law the the
the the fi it seems like the father and
the son were always
at war like uh saddam and uday i
remember one time
i think they did um did they one time
accidentally
shoot off his uh uncle saddam's uh
brother brother to that story
uh this is after i left oh that's after
you right here
yeah after i left i heard from one of
these guys was with him
uh but i tell you about tamil hannah
what
was saddam food tester and
his saddam was calling me calling him
son you know more very close to him he's
a christian person
but he and his family work all for
saddam since
he was kid and
i remember was a party
and mubarak
president of egypt ex president
visit iraq and
camel hana did a party for them you know
as a welcome into the country
i think by order of saddam to do
welcoming party for them
we was like a few buildings and
i'll have one here and we're coming from
habanero to this place where it's called
probably palace
space or something like that as i can't
translate it exactly
in english
i was sitting and oh they he was going
around
camel hannah invited every single one
except all day
and at the time
was a few months or less a year
saddam married secretly and this is what
i
break the news when i come out
another woman her name is amira
and was through camel hannah
and today he hated camel hannah because
of that
how you get a woman and is that of my
mother
and here was a war between them but he
can't touch him because
he know how valuable kamil han
to saddam and very close to him he can't
touch him
anyway he started drinking he can hear
the music and the singer from the other
side
how did he say to one of
these guys around him go tell him
because camel hannah
i think he become a little bit drunk he
took his machine gun a celebration you
know middle east
as a welcome
he told him go tell this idiot to stop
shooting
he went and he saw carmel and he was
and tamil hannah told him tell all day
i'm not taking order of him
the only person i took order of saddam
hussein
and like i was sitting in the couch and
my leg is up
when another guy was having fun drink
all day he had like a
uh sticker but very long with a hard
head
and you can't take take it up
as a sword when you pull it up with a
sword inside
he went and we go after him where are
you going
nobody talk to me nobody pushing here
i'm pushing here we want around
you want to calmly hannah with this
heavy stick
straight away to his head few times you
can
see the blue just keep going keep going
take the knife straight away cut his
neck
take the gun start shooting here and
there
everyone terrified they took mubarak
wife in a different car
straight away the palace informed
tamil hannah had been shot and winded on
that
i remember the president coming
enter the garden with the cars
a day he run to where he was
he went to the bathroom and closed the
door shut it down
completely screaming
in the bathroom we try
to open the door asking him to open the
door
nothing he keeps screaming screaming
till completely the voice is gone
and no more he can i can hear we call
him we call him no answer
we break the door he was on the floor he
took a lot of tablets
was i don't know what they are
a lot he took it a lot he went to kill
himself
put them in the car to the hospital was
hospital belong to the palace
called avensina
and this hospital they did what they did
with him
we was around him president come on
but he looked at everyone as a piece of
dirt
why he didn't stop him on this he took a
date
he wasn't lying in the bed and took him
like that start slapping him
you must be dead you must be this is
you're shaming me shaming the family
and anyway i will put you in the jail
for
all your life and if i can hang you but
i leave this to the justice league
and he put saddam order
he put the
george is the
one of the most powerful person in iraq
and he say don't look at him as my son
judge him
as a murderer for any person
and believe it or not okay we say what
they thinks a drum dictator and like
that
but the george he sent oda to that
penalty
audy mother contact king hussein
of jordan to involve
in this problem wow
uh oday has been taken
to really really horrible
prison cell really bad i mean bad you
know
three doors to go inside the cell
three doors and he by order of saddam
he don't give him except bread and water
nothing else bread water no
other another thing and if i hear
anybody treating him or
look at him after damn son i will
put him with him and he put i remember
three officers of his security
to spy if somebody break the rule
till one day we see the plane of
king jose arrived in baghdad
and president saddam he go to the
airport
pick him and clink hussain
of jordan involved to give
an amnesty to
oday and you know
in arabic ways or middle eastern ways
when somebody coming
asking you for forgiveness or all that
you should take it and you know this is
a king
and was you know friend with iraq and
like that
he can go back
with out of get what he want
and here saddam say
okay i don't let you go
without of do what you ask me but
he's a shame in me i don't want him in
iraq anymore
i want to kick him out of iraq and he
never come back here
and this is what they agree
he ordered i think all these
terms we can say to be
jailed you know
i've been put back to project seven i'm
not allowed to go anywhere
i think two and a half months we heard a
day
after he they sent him to switzerland as
an exile
don't come back he killed somebody else
in switzerland
because with the diplomatic community
he's not allowed to be arrested he's
being deported back to iraq
back again to same circle when he came
back he went back to the regular life
again
regular we don't say regular but
he become worse actually wait he became
worse when he got back
yeah worse worse i mean worse you know
it's not
like what he left before that
so was he the kind of person that hated
being humiliated by his dad
yes he was really
you know what you are saying when he
drunk
are you saying you know my dad go
when i become president i make every
iraqi
feel guilty saddam is gone and imagine
what he was thinking
um would you would you say he had a
deep hatred towards his father or no
like did he hate his dad or did
you know was it complicated
i hate love okay did he want to take
over that and be the president did he
have aspirations of being president yes
okay yes i can say this hundred percent
what was
in his head is his
uh even cause i
when you are saying you know sometimes
they are you you know
this is between order and kosa you don't
see them
very very rare they are together
you know very rare because they always
argue
and because i even he's younger he
telling him okay you want to be
president
after the president you know god gave
him life but with this behavior
you don't belong in this chair if you
get it
and this is always the argue between
them because they would say that today
or uday would say to you yeah
no because i saved all day got it
got it interesting yeah i mean you you
see these stories of what happens with
them so at what point did you say i got
to get out of this i don't want to do
this anymore how long did that take
because i know you said that your family
thought you were dead for two years but
two years later they found that you're
not dead
when did you say i want out of this life
i tried to kill myself
how what happened what caused you to get
to that point
uh one time was sitting in the top
uh building of uh iraqi olympic
committee
uh today he raped a girl
and the father he was very no one
in baghdad as a famous person you know
he coming to complain
and say to him you know you write my
doctor
and this and that
oh they were sitting behind his desk
office and
he started shouting them well what do
you want and your doctor she's a [ __ ]
and
you know he starts screaming and the
other
man he can't hear
somebody call his doctor who
he did something i as i remember it's
petting him or something bad word he say
i was sitting in this left the table
front of me fruit and
he threw his gun to me like that and he
said to me shoot him
i took the gun and i put it in this
chair
they say shoot him i say no i'm not
doing that
you want to shoot him you do it it's not
me no i order you to shoot you i said
okay
took the knife and i start cutting
myself
if you can see here
and here both sides
just the blood was all over
you crazy this with hospital they bring
me to hospital
uh yeah stitches and like does he come
on you're crazy or this
or that anyway
to make it a little bit shorter until i
met the president
you know i said to him i don't want to
complete work with this guy
uh he gave me a mercedes
300 seo was zero mileage in it
and before that
i've been tortured and thrown out of my
family house they didn't recognize me
because the guy what he said now in
jordan
he shaved my eyebrows my head
mustache you know this is a middle east
humiliation
my back you can't see only
lines is open blood
anyway i was really
sore you know they threw me like a piece
of potato like a bag of potatoes outside
the home
and my mother
my sister didn't recognize who i am only
through my voice
you know bold hair ball is nothing it's
like uh
boiled eggs they took me in and
[Music]
you are dead we did a funeral for you
you know how this happened i i told him
the story and
my dad he have a friend he have a
private hospital
in a good area
[Music]
he bring me to this hospital was a
poison in my blood
become you know muslims change all my
blood you know
from the torture and where they put me
and you know
like you know the manhole
with a lot of toilet stuff and
death cards that you know every rats
everything
with all these torture and my skin is
open and
infected they threw me in
inside this place and you know i get
really infected in my body completely
my dad he bring me to this hospital
i stay over 40 days there
i was really really saying with myself
that's it the rock is over for me it's
completely over
but what they teach me in intelligent
service
i should use it now against them
don't be stupid
and do it quick think about it and learn
what they teach you how and i was inside
and i know how
system worked
uh till one day after i really
get out of the hospital a little bit my
eyebrows
my hair started growing
he sent somebody and called me a day
he have a party and she
mansour hotel
he all these group got to be on mossy
common
before that i had a car
i am a fan of cars i really
up till now this age i buy anything
unusual about it
was a cadillac uh
if you see old videos of president ahmed
hassan bakker
long limousine black one i bought it
because of the history of it i bought it
and i want to sell it after one after
time one of his pimps
he want to buy it i said no i'm not
selling it and with the price you
want to buy it i say okay wait what's
going to happen
make it shorter he went today and told
him lottie
told me i'm not selling cars for all day
pimps
and here when he saw me and
hotel take this to me
shouting this i took my girl
what she was with me which is
what to the left want to go down before
the door closed you start shutting
through
and shipping then i get one in my
shoulder
go down i took my car i never stopped
till mosul
from the hotel till mosul but
i was being chased by
his gun you know but i'm a good driver
good more serious no stop and every
checkpoint i go
like half kilometer before
i put the sensor out of the lights
inside
they open the no check no nothing anyway
i went to mosul from mosul
they smuggled me to kurdistan
and another part of life start here
another chapter done so that was it you
were out you left everything that's the
laugh
november 1991
november 1991 so
the the assassination attempts then a
start you had three in vienna
i believe you had one in london and one
in norway right or am i missing one
correct
correct so they're still chasing you no
matter where you were going
yeah and when we say they is they would
they or is
is it uday uh uh kosei
and uh saddam not saddam
i can't say to you hundred percent and i
tell you the reason now
and definitely not kosei because i was
in contact with jose
it was all day got it so you know it
wasn't jose
you know it wasn't saddam but you know
what today's people that are coming
after you
yeah got it so you leave
you go and start your own uh new life
are you following everything with the
story
with the plans of wanting to retaliate
against oday and if yes how did you
okay here first of all
if i go back nearly 30 years back
one i don't write any book
two i'll be disappeared three
i don't be in the media for i never
say anything about my ex life and i live
my life
and i have my passport
my great family my this
since the book i wrote it
and i start in the media
my life demolished up till now i'm
talking to you
i don't have a life
even saddam gun even by afghan
even or they gone
but another chapter starts with
another government in here right now
exactly wars what they did to me
since saddam fell i have four death
penalty
issued by this new regime in iraq
why i was dreaming what intel do you
what intel do you have that scares them
that concerns them
i have a mouth and i know them and those
people
it was the same team of iraqi opposition
i know up and down of those guys
what the guy he was driving my kids omar
27 years ago to school
he become prime minister you imagine in
iraq
then another one she was a chef cooking
at my house she become third secretary
in iraq
and that's in holland you know everyone
out of my house you become leader now
a people you know ibrahimovic jafari
this
guy what you become second prime
minister in iraq
he's registered in london he's a
psychopath
he went to the social worker
excuse me pm herself because
they cut his 100 pound of rent
and now 6
billion pound here on in britain
6 million pound and this is a small fish
and when i talk maybe you visit my
channel on youtube
you know this is six channel verified
channel
they shoot it down for me 1.2 million
follower on youtube verify channel
page one tick gun
one and a half million on facebook
switch off
they find people they buy in people
because they don't want to hear their
dirt what i know about them
and i do life always i do life now with
with my follower even my enemy
they start following me and telling me
you tell them the truth
you know truth is hard truth
is hurt those guys what running
iraq make me personally
and this is first time i will say that
make me feel so sorry
i was opposition to saddam hussein
compare saddam to those guys he's a
prophet
coming from allah or god or call him
what he call him
compare to these guys saddam he didn't
kill in 35 years
what those people killed in the past 17
years
saddam he was running the country
up and down and you have every month
food
you got your local shop you get it for
free
it was running iraq 10 billion
pounds okay a year
now 130 billion
dollar i say a year
half of the nation living from rubbish
they don't have
food 17 years of democracy
no alchemicity no water no education
no medical health no system no nothing
absolutely
nothing we have most of gun
destroyed as a flat land now
but the muscle of history
every sunni area has been destroyed
i'm not against anybody not a religion
no anything
nothing i never talk religion because
for me
religion is destroying of mind
no matter which way i never talk
religion
or believe in this or that i believe
what here
i believe what i see i believe what i
read
and after that i make my mind you don't
come to me and tell me 1400 years ago
something happened
where is your proof the story we can't
tell story
those people and they are not even shia
you know they saying they are shia but
for me no i have a lot of
friends here they are nice people they
are educated people they are
they don't have this hate for other
people
you know i have so much iranian friend i
have a friend from japan
from everywhere and do i never look at
the person
which religion or background common you
know
latino question for you because
sometimes when when you know anytime we
do interviews with anybody
we we we will typically do extensive
research and the team will get a lot of
data and we'll contact some people some
of the people will say
some of the stories you say you over
exaggerate and it didn't have you know
you have to
say yeah they're fake they're not real
it didn't happen you waited for them to
die until you told the story when uday
died and then you came up
so some of the people are saying that
about you what do you say to people that
say
none of these things you talk about are
true you've made up what do you say to
them
three newspapers wrote this three of
them they are a friend to each other
one he starts he's in ireland
he's not a journalist two
nothing to do with journalism three when
he wrote the article
to the guardian in britain
he wrote it as opinion if you go
search of this guy background
bagged me in ireland to come and do and
to review with me
and i welcome him to my home what is not
easy for me to bring somebody to go home
but this guy he'd been paid to something
new
one he's not a journalist he writes
a small line and local paper
about a new pubs opening area a new
restaurant open
and i wrote a full article on my website
about him
but at the time give me one
whole world from trump
to smallest person in the world not
being
humiliated by media if he's
you know no one uh
or he have enemy or have you know
jealousy kill
some time when they say in lot if nobody
heard about him till
he wait a day and because i die and let
it come
out no in 1993 my facebook coming out in
vienna by
norcal per lag was a book
thousand page okay
1993 this is ten years early of odeon
jose
when the book come out i get the first
assassination attempt i think few
weeks later second assassination attempt
was a bomb under my car
and everything has been
documented by the australian
intelligence service
but they don't want to say it why
because
was an agenda between iraq and two
countries
financially was at the time controlling
austria was iran
and iraq you know there was control on
the intelligence service
they have everything in vienna you know
was iranian government and iraqi
government
at the time all the iraqi embassies
after the second goal for the invasion
of kuwait
has been shut down except two one in
switzerland
and one in vienna
was international uh law and they close
everything they don't have anything
and i was fighting okay
in 1994 i get the assassination attempt
in 1995 i get assassination attempt
and 19 in march 1995
i come to london running from australia
i've been shot here but the bullet
doesn't come to me was
one of my guys again how they
personally called me i was wishing
at the time in 95 like we have this
technology can record for the phone you
know
they say to me 3rd of july
1995 your dad is here and my office
if you don't stop you never see your dad
again
hey go this is your dad
i talked to my dad the one word say to
me
god make my life god he take it not this
[ __ ]
okay this brave man
4th of july next day after 12 hours i
think no more on that
my father was killed
i paid the price until now i am eating
myself
because of that but again
were those people was okay
when i said we can't say media
can be full right media they have the
resources
and half of the media they have very
good connection with intelligent service
that is not intelligent service police
secret service i don't know what
correct how can what if you're here
for the world from 92
up to 2003 right
to how can lot if you're here sit and
make up this
story if you read the book
i wrote it in 1992. correct
if i wasn't inside this how
i know every nails were at the palace
i described the past exactly how
i lived in it correct who can go
in this world to saddam palace and live
there
correct you can't drive even outside the
palace and like that how can i be
inside and describe all these
what inside the palace and the secret
and everything
and all that intelligent service here in
the west
they say to me oh now we found because
an
article or two somebody wrote about you
second journalist ed chizel
at caesar contract producing company
when
he was filming in malta
who is at scissor he's a friend with
this guy
in an island
okay he told him if you read the article
ex-wife x-ma i don't know what okay
give me one x if she was good
she don't be x correct
if she is an x she got to talk good
about love if you're here
no correct she got to fabricate the
story and say story and like that
but again i answer even she's my ex
because i don't like the drugs because i
don't like somebody stealing from my
bank account
because i don't like somebody sit
having sex and my house and my bed
when i'm traveling for business and when
i catch them
okay this is what's happened
this is the irish police
and when i been hit by irish police
21 stitches in my face broken nose
everything
since i've been injured this 11th
of april 2000 up till now
today 7th of december
2020. i want to bring this sergeant to
court i can't
with all the power i have with all the
money i have of all the lawyer i have
i can't this is the west
okay they can't put you up up but when
they finish off you
they destroy your life and here in the
west
you can see the fabrication of people
when they come and claim refugee status
and you can see the fabrication of a lot
of people
claim refugee status but they've been
sold itself
there they get the political refugee
status why is somebody like lot if
you're here
nearly 30 years 30 years
if i was killed killed 10
people i don't sit in a prison 30 years
correct
30 years only two years ago britain gave
me refugee status
two years ago okay wow
working paying tax my ex-wife she was
irish 18 years in ireland 22 million
euro investment no criminal record
my kids irish
my wife irish i own everything i don't
claim anything
but still no three times they reject me
minister of discretion why i found in
the end why
because i was one of my interviews
did with a
hard talk british polygraph
because i stripped the irish government
and this is the truth i didn't do
something
because they are corrupt i talk about
them because
they always ask bribery from me for any
project i do
must i give brown envelope to my project
began
it's like i'm sitting in iraq or iran or
i don't know where
it's not a european country
18 years with investment and everything
they reject me
i left ireland after they kicked me out
with no reason 18 years they give me
investor visa every year must i go
and get my renewal
2014 i want to renew it
they refuse why
you don't have any connection in this
country anymore
okay what what now what should i do you
leave the country
or you be by force deported to iraq
okay and i say you know what's happened
to me if i go back to iraq
we say this is what we can do i say
excuse me i say [ __ ] you and your
country now
my left
i left like a gypsy every day somewhere
i start from finland coming to sweden
coming to this
everyone reject me it's like i'm a
disease
somebody don't want to touch me why
because they think
i'm in trouble for them they think if
something happened to me
the country got me blamed
right i come to britain
i claim refugee status
my partner she's british
my two kids british
and they don't want to give me they
don't want or give me
three and a half years i have companies
i have business i have everything
but i am not allowed to work you're
paying tax because okay
but you are not allowed to work till you
the decision come
you can see how the business work here
okay and every single day me and the
lawyer
sit call the home office and every
one we get he telling us different
story but we record all that we record
all that in the end
have somewhere we found to complain
about the home office what they don't we
send the three
free record each record 15 minutes
after the home office no i
record every single thing
five days later i get my refugee status
five days does not take more exactly in
my birthday
2018 14th of june
registered post come to me the first
month say to me must be signed here
i don't know what the net i open it full
status
because they're afraid i go with these
records out
so now you're you're safe now uh where
you are in britain you you can stay
there you can work you don't have to
worry about going to another place
no i'm not worried but i am worried
see saddam hussein at the time we know
the intelligence service house work
right after 2003
with these mullahs what common to iraq
they have already based
in britain they have very old base here
since
70s okay
the billions of pounds and dollars and
the wealth coming to britain from iraq
unbelievable here
the threat back to if you're here
do you know just last week the
intelligence service or the police
coming to my house
calling me your life in danger they put
alarm and every single window connected
to the police
they put a black box uh with the key
and the bottoms give it to me and my
partner
this must be with you and if i say
what's going on he said just if
something happened press this button
they know my life now
then your morals are down time on sudden
time i kind of play the game
and so downtime i can travel i can go i
can get
but now no you know and especially with
this age
when i was in ireland before i come to
britain i've been shot
i've been shot by shia militias but they
put five million for my head
and this is why i'm disabled now
where is the law where is the logic
what claim and love if you hear a
fabricated stove and like that
and now when people go before hundreds
of
people on media and company
why do you go google what if you're here
why always comment these bad articles
over 100 thousand page husband why all
these
people always they put this up
you know google kind of play with those
okay
why they put this because you see now
everything fast
when you google sun now and you put full
name
the first two line common okay
if some is good oh perfect i like this i
picked the perfect thing
i don't care about what the rest down a
flutter
oh the first article oh fabrication oh
he's live
he's that that's it this is the picture
straight away coming yeah
you know because people become lazy they
don't go
i don't say be investigator but
ask to get an answer you don't hear it
you don't hear it from here and there
i say to them i say to them all those
people
if you have and now
after the invasion you have all the
documentation
of iraqi intelligence service before
if you find anything again a slot if
you're here
and the problem with the cia and 1991
when they took me out
okay they checked me twice they put me
and lie detector okay
twice not one twice
and this is why they took me out
why they didn't take that at the time
was you know the kurdish war and
there was a turkish border why they
didn't take 200
a thousand [ __ ] almost there why they
took lot if you're here
because they know i wasn't lying
they saw all these holes in my body they
saw
all these torture they saw photos
and my id well they promised me to give
it to me back
but they took me out and they said we
sent the tournament seat again
this is why i don't talk to media a lot
with
all my respect to the media some of them
is good
but this is why i pull out i say
why i do it i create more enemy
because i tell how's work
and how i you know nearly 30 years in
the media i know
every single thing how is
sick okay who is better me or bbc in
britain
sure bbc right two days ago was a
program
about diana after 20 20
25 years channel 4 the british one
take the dirt off bbc 25 years ago what
they did with diana
all fabrication all the lie they bbc did
to her
till being killed and they are now
in a really catastrophic way and this is
a bbc the channel of the
country of course fabriquette fabricate
a story
against who diana she's a princess she's
not love if you're here
and she's killed and now all that they
are coming out
lie is short correct
if they had anything
against love if you're here long time
ago was in the media
i don't want to somebody say he and she
no put a document
what the people said about me was the
pimp
i was talking about them in the
beginning of the program
do you understand where i get it i know
clearly which one you're talking about
yeah i know clearly which one you're
talking about this story by the way a
couple questions
was there a double for saddam as well or
no did he have a double because there's
rumors he had a lot of doubles
i so one okay
just one anybody else
and i was laughing about this book or
the guy what he
intelligent saddam
the cia or something when he wrote the
book he says saddam he say i don't have
double
no one go to say i have double because
when you have double does mean the
coward
yeah answer that we don't chow he's a
coward person
got him correct yeah
that's how you and then his his sons
when they got killed july 22nd
oh three i believe it's july 2203. what
were they killed from i know there was a
assassination attempt but what do you
know the story because
i've heard a lot of different versions
of it
the man what he say
whereas odai and kosai he
told the american they are there
because this when they come unto this
guy
i think how they and jose as i heard
from a sister of them okay
this is more and you can go more closer
of that
uh i think they give him a three million
dollar
to stay a week until
they started because they was being
kicked
from syria and they don't have anywhere
to go
till they go to this guy what they know
him he was a part of
friends of saddam or something like that
and he went to america and told them
they are in my house for three million
dollars
yeah plus the 25 of each together
god 53 53
and he's uh and monaco now
very happy wow so he made his 53
doing it that way well if i got to tell
you you got a lot of stories and i
appreciate you being uh
uh cooperative and just kind of you know
taking every question and
giving your perspective on what you have
i got to tell you i remember the first
time i saw the movie
and the actor that plays you and uday
dominic yeah he did a great job i mean
what a gr that movie
the acting in that movie is impeccable i
mean i gotta tell you a lot of respect
for that movie when i saw it i said
this is not an easy movie to do this is
not easy to be two parts
but he did a great job of portraying
the stories of what happened with you
and uday
but about the movie
[Music]
is not all true as you know as you saw
they breached the contract with 11
paragraph
i sued them i went
and i hope got to be remade
for full story this time would not
change how the
director changed it you know
hollywood hollywood has to add their own
spice to it sometimes you know they do
it whatever
it's not not in this way because
the script i told them if something's
changing the script
must i see it and sign for it
this is why the breach of 11 paragraph
wasn't it
that's why i get my right back
very interesting you you got a lot of
interesting stories and
like i said at the beginning you've
lived an interesting life you said not
an interesting life a rough life at the
beginning
and uh congratulations on finally being
a refugee of uh
britain and the family that you're over
there and i hope uh
everything works out for you from here
on moving forward
thank you so much patrick good to see
you and good to meet you thank you
thank you i don't know about you when
you listen to the story for the first
time it almost doesn't seem
real you know it's like hey you know i
was a double and you watch the movie you
read the book you read the article this
is
if this story is true this is a this is
an insane story
of uh what he went through i want to
hear your thoughts comment below what
your takeaway was
uh and if you enjoyed this story i did
an interview with the youngest sergeant
major in 2003 2004 i believe he got
promoted
to sergeant major when iraq goes down he
was the 21st
soldier of the iraqi army at 17 18 19
years old he becomes a sergeant major if
you haven't heard this story
it's a phenomenal story of hamudi jassim
if you've not watched it click over here
watch it and if you've not subscribed to
the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye